we
as has become our want are working our
way chapter a week
uh through uh through our forthcoming
book which will be out in september a
hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century
last week or in episode 87 we talked
about chapter four we read a brief very
brief excerpt from chapter four which
was
a chapter called medicine and this week
we're going to talk um
a bit about food and really you know as
the idea of this book in part was that
every single chapter could be one or
more books unto themselves
and certainly that is true um certainly
that is true for this chapter
and um this is this is a long excerpt
this week but i think
um i think it's all it's all relevant
and good this is actually the beginning
of the chapter and it's you know by no
means a majority of it but um it is a
long
excerpt so chapter five of a
hunter-gatherer's guide to the
21st century food what is the best diet
for
humans people have been preoccupied with
this question for a long time
especially weird people many of us have
tried diets that are supposed to be what
our ancestors ate
but the lens with which we do this tends
to be reductionist and a
evolutionary at best from diets designed
to alter the ph of your body to those
based on your blood type to those that
restrict your intake to one or a few
kinds of food
like grapefruit or cabbage soup weird
people are both obsessed with and
confused by the question of what to eat
let's take just two diets that are
popular in some circles two that seem
less crazy than many
the raw diet and paleo those who
advocate for a raw diet suggest it is
the healthiest
most natural way to eat cooking they say
is a modern bastardization of the human
diet
this is simply wrong not only is cooking
ancient in the human lineage it also
allows us to get more calories from food
and while it may be true that cooking
can reduce some of the vitamins in the
food that has been cooked the benefits
far outweigh this small cost
people and entirely raw food diets are
often undernourished especially if those
diets are also vegan
they are generally thin but that
thinness is not inherently healthy
others argue for the health of the
so-called paleo diet a diet free of
grains and most carbohydrates and high
in fat
this may well be a healthy diet for some
people
but those who came from lineages whose
cuisine is rich in carbohydrates
people from the northern mediterranean
for instance
may not be best served or most healthy
on such a diet
furthermore there is growing evidence
that early humans are eating a diet rich
in carbohydrates from starchy
underground vegetables
relatives of which include the african
wild potato as much as 170
000 years ago this suggests that while
healthy for some the paleo diet is not
particularly reflective of paleo ways of
life
these are only two of today's many
modern approaches to diet but they
reveal two similarly misguided
assumptions about food
first they imply that there is a fixed
and universal answer to the question of
what one should eat
just as we discussed with regard to
medicine the chances of this being true
are vanishingly small
differences in individual development
will render some foods healthy for one
person
less so for her neighbor demographics
such as what sex you are will affect
what food is best for you
and the simple act of aging will change
the answer as well
cultural differences which are often
based in geography may well affect your
optimal diet
and those cultural differences may have
moved into the gene layer reflecting
population level genetic predispositions
to particular foods
as with the lactase persistence of
european pastoralists and saharan
bedouin
again remember the omega principle which
posits that expensive and long lasting
cultural traits like cuisine should be
presumed to be adaptive
and that adaptive elements of culture
are not independent of genes
the second misguided assumption that
many such diets reveal is that they seem
to presume that food is merely for
survival
the evolutionary truth is that food is
for more than just survival
food is more than nutrients vitamins and
calories
like all animals indeed all heterotrophs
we eat to acquire the energy and
nutrients necessary to be alive
but the human relationship with food
like that with sex has expanded beyond
its original purpose
humans no longer eat merely to satisfy
energetic requirements any more than we
have sex just to make babies
an historic and a historical
reductionist approach to diet attempts
to replace food with its component parts
take this supplement eat that bar drink
the contents of that can
you'll get x grams of protein a handful
of alphabetically named vitamins and
that rush of energy you've come to
expect
to get you through your day as is so
often the case such an approach creates
hyper novelty which then creates new
problems of its own problems that we are
too often defenseless against
the mistakes inherent in this approach
are many and the hubris abundant
the 20th century saw the dismantling of
chesterton's cuisine
as suggested by chesterton's fence we
ought to have understood what cuisine
was for before we took it apart
in its place we got easily quantified
and commodified pieces and parts that
can be added and subtracted in a whim by
the producers of processed food
instead of chasing the newest diet
advice with processed food now with more
b12
we should be eating real food real food
is that in which the base ingredients
are recognizable as coming from a living
organism
there are just a few exceptions like
salt
some things taste delicious and
flavorful to everyone rich and succulent
and salty and crispy and sweet and
smooth are combinations that are beloved
across cultures
our sense of taste evolved in an era
when meat and other fatty foods salt and
sugar were all rare
our sense of flavor is thus evolved and
important
this is true and it is true that our
sense of flavor can be and
is gamed in a system that can easily
create fat salt and sugar
and add them to any food stuff it wants
another manifestation of hypernovelty
fast food tastes good to many people
because it successfully gains our sense
of taste
accessing single notes fatty salty sweet
in a reliable uniform way that can be
triggered anytime you order the same
thing in any one of hundreds of
identical stores
by contrast a plate of carne asada rice
and beans with freshly made tortillas
pico de gallo guacamole and pickled
vegetables from a local taco standard
from your own kitchen
will always be more nutritious and more
delicious too for many of us and for
anyone who chooses to develop a palette
that finds it so
that plate of less processed more
species diverse food is more nutritious
than a plate of fast food
just as it is more nutritious than
taking pills you're supposedly a match
for all the nutritional benefits you're
getting from your food
the whole is greater than the sum of its
parts
but why is the whole greater than the
sum of its parts or to put it another
way
why is a holistic approach often better
than a reductionist one
two reasons first the parts of a given
system that we have turned into pills
are usually not descriptive of the whole
system
remember the discussion of vanillin a
component of vanilla and thc a component
of marijuana from the previous chapter
second there is often emergence in the
combination of food in its less
processed form such that our bodies can
use food more effectively that it can
use pills
this is especially true for those foods
that have a long culinary history
together
such as the three sisters of corn beans
and squash traditionally eaten by
mesoamerican peoples
when these foods are eaten together they
constitute a complete protein
such a long culinary history points to
the human discovery
usually unconscious that just as smells
good was a good proxy for
good for you until recently so too was
tastes good
a good proxy for good for you
reductionism in our approach to food
fails us as our bodies are not static
simple systems
nor do all individuals have the same
needs there is no universally best diet
for humans
there can't be in our varied
environments of evolutionary adaptedness
there were a few staples
in the andes quinoa and potatoes were
generally on the menu
in the fertile crescent of mesopotamia
wheat and olives were among the foods
domesticated early
in sub-saharan africa sorghum and
guineans were significant early
agricultural successes
there was meat sometimes in short-lived
abundance there was fruit seasonally
also in abundance
there was alcohol intermittently and
botanically created stimulants in some
places
in those places those stimulants were a
regular but low key part of life
even the ratio of macronutrients is not
stable between cultures
inuit have a high fat high protein diet
with almost no carbohydrates
which is unlike almost any diet that
evolved closer to the equator
given such variation the idea of a
universally best human diet seems
patently absurd
in the 21st century there are many
foodstuffs available that will trick you
into eating them even when parts of you
are sensing that it's a bad idea to do
so
before the advent of cheap always
available highly processed food our
ancient aesthetic preferences made a
very good guide to what to eat
those ancient aesthetic preferences
aren't so reliable now
hyper novelty has gamed our ancient
rubrics about what to eat and what not
to and thus
we must use our consciousness to
separate the good from the bad
reductionism in our approach to food
also fails us in that it ignores food's
ability to provide connection to other
humans with the family and friends who
cooked for or with you or for whom you
cooked
a reductionist nutrient-centric approach
to food fails to allow for celebration
or for grief both of which are often
accomplished through food
it fails to recognize and remember
cultural tradition and to consider
flavors that have come together through
serendipity and experimentation
cuisines old and new reflect both their
terroir the land from which they emerged
and their borrowing from other cultures
and places those three sisters of corn
beans and squash are still dominant in
mexican cuisine
limes garlic and cheese all introduced
by the spanish to people in the new
world have been incorporated deliciously
as well
humans do not just need protein and
potassium and vitamin c
we generally need those things in the
food context and what's in which our
ancestors ate them
we also need culture and connection when
we sit down to eat a meal together
especially when we are breaking bread
that we have ourselves made we gain far
more than calories
let us now look to our evolutionary
history how we ate and what we ate as a
way to understand how best we might feed
ourselves today
and that will be the next section
you know when i hear you read that
section i can almost
see why our critics see us as simpleton
grifter zealots i mean kind of comes
through in that section a little a
little
yeah all right um yeah that's uh
fantastic i i i wonder i'm of course
very curious to know what other people
hear when they uh when they hear that
description
especially in light of the fact of it
uh not staking out a standard paleo
position
right um and obviously
making rational critiques of
current dietary fads yeah so i guess um
maybe before we riff on this a little
bit and before we get into some of the
other literature i want to i want to
walk us through today
um starting in chapter three of this
book and i haven't done it until now
we have at the end of each chapter
something that we call the corrective
lens
in which you know to the degree that
this is in fact a hunter-gatherer's
guide to the 21st century
we we give some some sort of operational
advice
on uh you know what you might do that is
apropos the topic
of the chapter at hand and so the
corrective lens section for the food
chapter is pretty long
but i thought i'd just share three of
the of the many more than that bullet
points from it and let's
um let's refund these let's see um
well we begin this corrective lens
section by saying we might call this
section the new kosher
most ancient dietary laws are now out of
date but that does not mean that we
couldn't use some rules around how what
and when to eat
avoid gmos gmos are neither inherently
dangerous nor inherently safe
they are however different from the
artificial selection that farmers have
been engaging in for thousands of years
when farmers chose choose plants or
animals to breed promoting some traits
and down regulating others they are
playing within the landscape that
selection has already been acting on
in contrast when scientists insert genes
or other genetic material into organisms
that have no recent history with those
genes
they are creating an entirely new
playing field sometimes they will be
lucky
and the result will be useful and kind
to humans sometimes they will not be
lucky
chimerical life forms that have been
created by humans using hyper novel
techniques are not inherently safe
anyone telling you otherwise is either
mistaken or lying to you
we also have um exposed children to a
diverse range
of whole foods especially ones that
connect them to your culinary and ethnic
background
eat the same food that you put in front
of them and show obvious enjoyment of it
keep seasonal produce on your counter
and let the children eat any fruit that
they find there encouraging them to
develop their own preferences while they
also learn how and when
to explore a variety of whole foods
and
do not forget that food is social
lubrication for humans
eating alone in your car after visiting
the drive-through is a novel situation
and it's not helping us connect with our
food our bodies and their needs
or one another i mean i think
that's one of probably the thing that
people will see coming the least
uh in this in this chapter most of which
is about the actual stuff that we should
be eating and preparing and and
how to combine it and such um and the
history of our doing so but
the fact of food not being just about
sustenance not just being about calories
and nutrients but actually about
you know one one of the ways that we
connect with one another and see our way
through not just celebration and grief
you know celebration and mourning
festivities and
and funerals uh but also just the
the daily cementing of bonds right the
the the fact that you can come to rely
if you are
if you are lucky enough to live uh in a
in a loving family or in another
situation
in which the people with whom you share
a living situation
come together reliably with food over
food that you have either made
or or brought in or or go out to
to find together uh that
those moments bring people together
uh in a way that's it's just easier i
think people have their guard down when
they're sharing good food
um and especially when it was prepared
by one or more of the people who are who
are sharing it
yeah if you uh in fact had a list in
front of you
of the people you know and the people
with whom you have
broken bread you would find that the
broken bread with list
is a special list almost inevitably yeah
and maybe that's um you know at this
point especially especially since we're
still
you know close to we're on the near
side of um having been effectively
forced into not interacting with people
not into and
basically know travel for so long that
we now know many people
um we feel like we know well but we've
never met
in person and the fact is upon meeting
in person what you tend to do is
break bread right we tend to do that and
that's not
it's not that we actually need to be
eating all the time we really don't
it's that that is a way to bond that is
an historic way to bond and
nothing about the modern environment
should have changed that right and in
fact
if you if this was anything but the
modern environment
breaking bread with somebody would force
certain things that it no longer does
right you can break bread with somebody
where you've sourced food from
you know i don't know a good restaurant
or something like that and so it still
has the same
symbolic value but it's not the same
thing as
uh cooking a meal for somebody you know
having them over and
thinking about what you know what you
might want
to eat with them what you know puts you
and your your family in their best light
some
favorite meal or something like that
yeah but i wanted to highlight something
you know there are a couple of major
themes
in our book one of them is this hyper
novelty issue
one of them is the synergy of the
various different
levels of analysis and then i think a
third one
is the recognition that we are stuck
in this intermediate state where the
ancient ways
are not directly applicable the modern
ways
are almost universally hazardous
and one has to figure out how to steer
a rational course that recovers
as much of the ancestral wisdom as is
useful
and then rationally approaches the
topics on which one can't have a
traditional
view in some reasonable way and this is
sort of
mirrored by another phenomenon an
evolutionary phenomenon itself
which is everything i think this is
logically true
everything everything we might call an
adaptation
has some initial cause some problem that
it solved or opportunity that it opened
but many of these things especially in
the human context
nowhere more true than in the human
context many of these things
have picked up other values right so
uh you read this about you know sex not
being just about producing babies now
obviously
at the evolution of sex it was origin of
sex that's what it is
right and it really is that for
most creatures and then we get to a
small list of creatures for whom that's
not exactly true
right for whom there appears to be
augmentation and elaboration and
basically a borrowing of that mechanism
for other things but it's really a tiny
handful of creatures it's a kind of
social glue
right and then in human beings we find
something
really utterly remarkable right which is
that
the primary purpose may in fact now be
in some sense secondary it's necessary
but the primary purpose may have to do
with um
you know bonding relationship
maintenance and not with direct
you know it's not that those two things
are inherently different obviously
in humans because the babies are so
labor-intensive to raise well
a pair bonded couple or
more a pair bonded couple in the family
that they bring to the table
are you know necessary to
the proper raising of the children and
therefore the social bonding phenomenon
is reproductive in some very uh indirect
way
but nonetheless more on that in two
three and four weeks right
those chapters yeah but but my point is
okay so here you see it with
food right actually but before you
before you go on i want to say that um
to some degree i think um the fact that
you know you've just posited that
perhaps
obviously the the you know the reason
for sex to exist
um as is is about reproduction
and um it's possible that in humans one
could understand that to actually have
become a secondary
a secondary function in many cases and
that would almost
have to have been true in order for the
level of confusion
that a lot of society now has over you
know what sex is and you know how
fundamental it is and whether or not you
can actually change what you are so
again
the sex and gender chapter is two
chapters from now and we'll talk about
it
right fairly extensively